foreign
[Music]
executive producer of Minecraft Legends
and today we'd like to give you an
Insider's look at how we're building the
PVP multiplayer experience for the game
Minecraft Legends is a new action
strategy game set in a lush Dynamic
World it introduces epic storytelling
and you can form alliances with new and
familiar Minecraft Mobs to stop the
invading piglets
Minecraft Legends will let you play the
story-driven campaign as an online co-op
experience together with your friends
and it will also feature a PVP gameplay
mode where two teams with up to four
players each Works to destroy the
opponent's team space
the game will support cross-platform
play and online matchmaking
in order to create the best possible
experience we partner with Blackbird
interactive to develop the game
and it's been wonderful to see their
commitment and focus on the Minecraft
Universe
it's so much fun to be working with
moyang Studios on Minecraft Legends here
at Blackbird interactive we have a
talented team of developers who are
using our background and strategy games
to bring a new and exciting experience
to the Minecraft Universe we're super
excited to share more details about PVP
gameplay
[Music]
PVP unique first off players share their
army and resources with their team
this means that individual players
aren't able to win on their own they
must cooperate to be successful
communication is really important and
you can sort of really tell the teams
that gel together because they naturally
form roles at the beginning of the game
and as soon as we start you're off
collecting I start building we already
we have our favorite roles but we change
them up
also the world in PvP is procedurally
generated just like it is in campaign
this means that each PVP session is
different than the last
every time you play depending on how the
map is generated where the valleys are
the mountains are where the secrets are
you know where the towers are
in Minecraft Legends the piglens are an
ever-present threat and this includes
PVP the piglands are on their own side
they're trying to kill both of you at
the same time
so the opposing team is not the only
thing you need to worry about
Beware of the piglands
there's something for everyone
players who like action they can go
attack the piglands or lay Siege to the
enemy base for players who enjoy
exploration they can search the world to
find resources for their team hidden
treasure chests or Scout the enemy base
Gathering resources to help the team out
that's super important but whenever I
get into a PVP match the first thing I
try to do is to track down the Regal
tiger it's my favorite mob to ride
because it's really fast but it's also
really cute
for players who like building you can
spend your time building defenses and
upgrading your base because soon enough
your enemy will attack and you need to
be ready
so the first thing I do when we start is
everyone runs off I open the map see
where the enemy base is first thing I
build is what we call an upgrade Tower
which allows you to build upgrades so I
place that at the back away from the
enemy
so I really pride myself in making you
know impenetrable bases
since the goal of PVP is to destroy the
opposing team's base Defending Your Own
base is really important you have to
start with a lot of walls a lot of
towers and some gates
after that you can just add whatever you
want freestyle a little bit
I like to add different layers of walls
so my opponents have to find their way
through to my base almost like a maze
and then once those walls are up I like
to actually hide my ice traps behind
them to catch enemies off guard
when it comes time to finally take out
the other team my favorite strategy is
to make a forward Camp just outside the
enemy base then I get the biggest
strongest mobs I can as fast as I can
and start sending them in
then I can smash Down the Walls take out
their mobs and claim victory
the real fun of PVP is creating a
strategy having a game plan deciding how
you think you're going to crush the
enemy and then all of a sudden the hosts
tell you
builds a redstone
and you're like I can't do my attack now
I've got to like build an anti-seage
Tower which is an anti-air Tower to stop
the Redstone launches you just have to
be constantly changing your tactics
and sometimes you'll have no idea what
they're doing and then you soon you
certainly find out very quickly
resources
a while back we had somebody on our Dev
team use a strategy where they built a
bunch of what are called plank Golems
which are archers so they're very weak
but they do a high amount of damage and
he had 40 of them and he just ran
through our base ran around our Tower
and took out our entire Tower with such
a simple strategy and that's why we
still love playing it every day because
every game is different you never know
what's going to happen
[Music]
thank you
see you
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Chris osaki and welcome
to turn 10 Studios
the team is hard at work bringing you
the next generation of Forza Motorsports
built from the ground up to take
advantage of the Xbox series consoles
this is the most technically Advanced
racing game ever made today I'm joined
by some of our amazing team members to
show you how we are making it look real
sound real and feel real
this is Forza Motorsport
at launch the Forza Motorsport features
over 500 cars for you to collect race
and customize with more than 800 unique
upgrades this includes over 100 new to
Motorsport cars the most modern race
cars we've ever featured on our roster
racing is violent it's a battle on the
race track the advancements in our
physics model are greater than Forza
Motorsport 5 6 and 7 combined this makes
our Driving Experience more fun and
rewarding in the way the car accelerates
corners and breaks our materials and
shaders are built from the ground up at
higher resolutions and optimized for a
Cutting Edge Ray tracing experience
our paints are sourced using a
spectrophotometer to capture multiple
data points of light behavior on a
Surface this yields a paint model that
has a much more realistic light response
across color metal flake and gloss
damage and dirt buildup is unique to
each car it's now contextually aware and
more localized we simulate paint
thickness chipping and directionality
dirt accumulation is more realistic
Gathering more in the low pressure areas
like recesses and alcoves these
Innovations tell the story of the work
you put into a race and reflects the
marks and Battle Scars of Motorsport
this is our best sounding Fortune
Motorsport ever and the first to be
mixed natively for immersive audio
formats like Windows Sonic and Dolby
Atmos
to create an immersive soundscape each
audio system has been rebuilt from the
ground up to deliver a new level of
Sonic depth and authenticity for our
players modifying car parts like your
exhaust and turbo change the car sounds
in Forza Motorsport just like it would
in the real world every car now has a
variety of sound possibilities based on
the parts you've installed Hardware
accelerated convolution Reverb
accurately reproduces how sounds in
Forza interact within an acoustic space
dynamically adapting to its surroundings
and creating a realistic and detailed
soundscape
foreign
new features like our regional track
announcer system and improved Tire and
Suspension audio bring a new level of
realism to the game
here for to Motorsport like never before
every tire squeal every engine lap after
life
[Applause]
[Music]
Forza Motorsport launches with 20
environments built from the ground up
for this generation you'll get to race
on iconic fan favorites as well as five
all new to Motorsport locations
including our first in South Africa
kyalami
we capture our environments to an
incredible level of detail when we
reference a track our team comes back
with over three terabytes of highly
detailed photogrammetry and Laser scan
data
the power of the Xbox series consoles
were able to use this data to draw up to
10 times more detail than previous
generations you'll see Lush trees dense
grass and overgrowth vegetation animated
track life physically based lighting and
volumetric fog effects and a fully
procedural cloud system that evolves
organically tracks look alive sound
alive and feel alive with cutting-edge
visuals and crowds consisting of tens of
thousands of fully animated 3D
Spectators so you're always immersed in
the pure spectacle of racing for the
first time in Forza Motorsport fully
Dynamic time of day with weather ensures
a constantly evolving Racing Experience
where no two laps ever look the same
meanwhile Dynamic track temperatures wet
driving surfaces and rubbering in ensure
that no two laps ever play the same
I love the detail our talented team of
artists have built into kailami
[Music]
and the Vista is truly breathtaking
the distant light blows of the city a
beautiful visual touch even the kyalami
logo itself creates visual impact every
time you see it thanks to raytrace
Global illumination which simulates how
hundreds of thousands of light rays
accumulate color as they bounce between
surfaces we're rendering all our
environments in 4k at 60fps with
real-time Ray tracing on track to create
true to life Reflections on all smooth
mirror and flat glass surfaces
with the incredible detail and rendering
features of our track environments Forza
Motorsport is truly a generational leap
ahead with unmatched visual Fidelity and
authenticity
[Music]
Forza Motorsport is back and it's our
most comprehensive game ever with over
500 cars and 20 environments with more
new race cars than ever before
you can experience all of this in our
incredible new online racing mode and in
our all-new car building focused single
player career
we cannot wait for you to get your hands
on this incredible game
[Music]
foreign
that's me and you're probably wondering
how I ended up here well it's pretty
standard
check this out
the player in my chest it's powering up
my new robot arm
making everything sync up with the beat
let's rock this is awesome
what in the hell am I looking at the
name's chai not defects
we'll take down this company one boss at
a time
just so you know they're insane
Rockstar
future Rockstar
I'm Shinji mikami Studio head at the
time gamingwalks thank you for all your
support over the years and I'm John
Johannes director on hi-fi Rush
[Music]
chill out it'll be fine
um
so everyone thinks of us as putting out
horror games like The Evil Within or
spooky games like ghostwire Tokyo but
this is clearly something totally
different and if this game hasn't
already leaked fingers crossed we hope
it's a pleasant surprise
let's have some fun
foreign
so we've been waiting for this for a
long time so let's jump in and explain
exactly what Hi-Fi Rush is
[Music]
high five Rush is a rhythm action game
so it's a bit of a Twist on your
traditional action game here your moves
and attacks help create a living
soundtrack that means all your flashy
moves stylish and devastating combos add
a layer to the music
the more you flow with the beat the
better you can connect your attacks and
abilities
you are in total control during combat
but everything you do synts up like an
awesome music video
that's HiFi Rush
you play as chai
wannabe Rockstar and victim of a weird
corporate experiment that lets him sense
the rhythm of the entire world pulsing
to the game soundtrack
[Music]
as you can see the beat moves the world
around you and it's the key to combat
you looking for me your attacks will
automatically sink to land on the beat
making Hi-Fi Rush a super easy game to
start playing
however attacking on the beat leads to
combos that end with a musical countdown
we call a Beat hit think a big cymbal
crash at the end of a drum Zone like
this
Landing beat hits on the Chicago finish
that adds unique musical Flair and high
damage attacks
and The Crowd Goes Wild
oh
um
anyone see the guy that did this
[Music]
how about we see it all in action
foreign
[Music]
by the music you can jump Dodge parry
and attack whenever you want using
whatever attacks you want
it's not about mashing buttons
the key here is feeling the beat
[Music]
your progress isn't blocked by missing
the beat but you get rewarded musically
and mechanically for staying in rhythm
[Music]
when we say everything moves to the beat
we mean it enemy attacks
cutscenes
dangerous obstacles
you name it
it all syncs to the music creating an
ongoing jam session of a game
[Music]
to help out is 808 your robot cat
companion who literally hovers over your
shoulder and helps you find that rhythm
but we also have visual guides to help
you even more
we want you to be able to enjoy Hi-Fi
Rush whether you're Rhythm Pro or not
so cool doing this
chai also gets by With a Little Help
from his friends
literally huh
slacker we've got work to do chai will
team up with unlikely allies to expand
its repertoire of moves both in and out
of combat there's peppermint breaking
barriers and juggling enemies along with
macarons smashing enemy armor and
knocking backhanded
tag teaming with chai's partners and
attacks opens up huge possibilities for
dynamic Combos and over-the-top action
that's not bad
the extra help is handy because when
you're not fighting you're going to be
running around and wreaking havoc all
over vandelay's corporate headquarters
where everything is trying to take you
down you and your partners have a
singular goal in mind
taking down the boss's vandelay
Technologies
besides wanting to erase chai for being
a defect it seems they've got something
a little bit more Sinister on their
corporate agenda
you'll fight through each department to
take them all on each level with their
own musical spin on the Rock genre and
then we have a showdown
[Music]
so let's get ready to crumble boss
battles are climactic set pieces varying
from straight up fights and musical
minigames to chase sequences
custom queries app to licensed music
from amazing artists
[Music]
Hi-Fi Rush is like nothing we've made at
Tango before
and we think it's like nothing you've
ever played before either
it's a high energy feel good Rhythm
action experience that's amazingly
satisfying to play
[Applause]
oh
Rockstar moved shy
[Music]
Ness
so not only were super psyched for you
to play this we're happy to tell you
that you can play Hi-Fi Rush tonight
not a demo the full game
seriously
it launches on Xbox and PC a few hours
after the show and yes it'll be on Game
Pass as well
we hope you enjoy playing Nick
you looking for me
mind if I join
[Music]
does that mean I have to fight I believe
it does sir
how about
this is entertaining you're going out
with the trash
here's your project Armstrong pass
and welcome to Mandalay campus
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Hunt Valley Maryland and the
headquarters of zenimax online Studios
you just saw a cinematic teaser for The
Elder Scrolls online's next chapter I'm
pleased to reveal ESO necron which will
launch in June and is shaping up to be
one of the best updates to the game ever
if you watch the teaser closely you saw
that necron will include one of the most
requested features in ESO a new playable
class called The Arcanist
it's only our third new class since
launch and we know you're going to love
it the arcanus wields magic influenced
by Forbidden Knowledge and has unique
abilities never before seen in this
world
of course the experience of exploring a
new area of Tamriel was the heart of
every ESO chapter necron will unfold an
Eastern Morrowind not seen in an Elder
Scrolls game since 1994 where you will
meet new characters and enemies reunite
with some old friends and explore a
story based around the return of a
well-known Daedric prince you just might
remember from the Dragonborn Skyrim DLC
for those of you new to ESO we release a
new expansion called a chapter every
year chapters are essentially Standalone
games in ESO that let you Adventure in a
new region of Tamriel but you don't have
to wait for the necron chapter to jump
in we've got so many amazing experiences
you can enjoy right now if you love
games like Skyrim and Oblivion you'll
feel right at home amongst the thousands
of stories unfolding across every region
in ESO
and as anyone who's played a classic
Elder Scrolls game knows it's all about
those feelings when you're fully
immersed in the world
remember that feeling when you first
encountered a dragon we've got an entire
Province that's overrun by dragons
or questioned if you were capable of
taking down a frost troll in Skyrim try
it for yourself in ESO
what about the moment you visited a city
in Morrowind that was built inside the
shell of a giant crab
for the Oblivion fans out there how
about another chance at taking on the
Colossal Daedric prince mayroon's Dagon
just like any single player Elder
Scrolls game you can have a blast simply
by following the main quest line
or seek out lore and learn more about
the world
become a Craftsman
go fishing
decorate and furnish your home
[Music]
customize your character
play it like an action RPG
and when you're ready you can easily
engage in one of the best open world PVP
systems
run dungeons co-op with your friends for
great loot
or just join a guild to chat with others
the possibilities in this virtual world
are endless
new players will immediately feel right
at home because our community is one of
the most if not the most welcoming on
the planet
we invite everyone who has not yet
experienced ESO to give it a try and
create your own stories in our shared
world there's no required subscription
and thousands of hours of content to dig
into solo
or with friends
explore nearly every corner of Tamriel
with no level restrictions it's magical
being able to travel almost anywhere you
please from the moment you enter the
world
ESO is available on PC and Mac in
addition to previous and current gen
consoles including a purpose-built
next-gen version for the Xbox series xns
with High Fidelity graphics and enhanced
performance modes an added bonus for
Xbox players it's on Game Pass
and starting today for a limited time
we're making all past chapters available
to explore for any player so everyone
can test drive all of our adventures
including our take on Skyrim Morrowind
Oblivion and much much more
at zoss we have so many passionate and
talented developers who continue to add
to Elder Scrolls lore by producing
handcrafted Epic Adventures and I'm
immensely proud to be a part of it
believe me we have tons more to share
and I can't wait for the team to show it
all to you
join us after this show for the 2023 ESO
Global reveal where we'll go deep into
all things necron
thanks see you in Tamriel
[Music]
foreign
something evil is swallowing up this
place bit by bit
nobody ever believes things can get this
bad until it happens
man
but
there are people who can fight back
stick together
[Music]
foreign
welcome to redfall Massachusetts where
the calm seas and sunny skies have been
eclipsed by a legion of vampires
redfall is a story-driven shooter at its
heart which can be played single player
or co-op with up to four players
choose your hero each with their own
unique abilities and form the perfect
vampire slaying Squad to take back red
Falls haunted streets
at Arcane we make games where the world
itself is as important as the characters
in redfall we take an exciting step
forward building a lovingly detailed
open world to deliver our largest
setting ever
inch of our open world is carefully
handcrafted and packed with
environmental storytelling
explore the streets of a quaint Island
Town
from the once bustling downtown to the
haunted forest to the decimated seaside
boardwalk and gorgeously detailed
landmarks
but it's not all danger all the time
there are safe places on the island
where you can rest up chat with
survivors and resupply
[Music]
here we're at the fire station one of
your home bases
this is one place you'll receive
missions from survivors
and I need you to do the Old Lighthouse
in the bay it's been used for over a
century to keep boats away from the
coastline if we turn it back on it's a
warning to anyone trying to come to
redfall right now easy right
well the Lighthouse Keeper is a real
joined up with those cultists
and took the damn lamp with him
here's a vampire known as the Shroud
shrouds blanket the area in darkness
disorienting their prey
they hurl lethal projectiles and can
even shift through the floor to avoid
damage
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
the lighthouse is back up but there's
more waiting for you taking down
vampires angers the vampire Gods who
will summon the Rook to take you down
let's transition to what you'll find
outside of the main story missions
there's so much waiting for you red ball
is filled with encounters that can pop
up anywhere like this Brewery that's
Fallen under cultist control save the
locals from being offered to the
vampires
like our past games you can approach a
mission in many different ways
always be ready to improvise
Remy uses her combat robot reborn to
help distract and eliminate the cultists
[Music]
foreign
yep
everyone's safe let's move on
exploring redfall will take you beyond
the bounds of reality as you investigate
otherworldly psychic spaces to unravel
the vampire secrets
take this vampire Nest these deadly
layers change each time you step inside
Jacob sends out his Raven to tag the
enemies below Dev follows up with his
teleporter instantly closing the gap
to destroy a nest you have to take out
its heart and all of the vampires
willing to die to protect it
horrible way to die
what just happened now Escape The Nest
before it comes crashing down it'll
collapse any second
nests aren't the only psychic spaces
you'll find dangerous pockets all over
the island
it's all vampire Turf so tread carefully
[Applause]
redfall won't truly be safe until the
vampires are wiped from the map outside
the main story another one of your
missions is to take back redfall
neighborhood by neighborhood
find safe houses hidden all over the
island and then work your way up to the
vampire controlling the neighborhood
to reclaim this neighborhood you'll have
to defeat a powerful vampire called the
siphon
whether you dive in Solo or with friends
each hero can take on any situation
each brings powerful unique abilities to
the fight and the upgrades you choose
change how they play
here Layla's lift ability can be
upgraded to launch teammates for
Airborne attacks upgrade Layla's
umbrella ability with bullet hail to
absorb enemy bullets and release the
energy back at them
foreign
there are many ways to customize your
hero's ability tree to match your
playstyle 99.
put some light on the subject
let's hit on the Arsenal there's a wide
range of Weaponry for military gear to
new vampire slaying inventions from
shotguns to sniper rifles
well well
and of course there's also vampire
Stakes find these in the world to
customize your weapons
when you reclaim significant sections of
redfall the last step is to face the
underboss who controls or used to
control that neighborhood
underbosses are powerful Elites of the
vampire Gods with their own unique
abilities like this one's Shield
foreign
against the underboss you'll receive a
key of sorts
a skull that gets you one step closer to
facing the ultimate threat the vampire
gods
thank you for visiting redfall and thank
you for all the support you've shown
Arcane throughout the years we sometimes
joke that our games can be tough to
define the one thing that's consistent
we make the kinds of games we love to
play and that's how redfall was born we
Blended everything we love here at
Arcane Austin immersive open worlds
unique and customizable heroes RPG and
FPS gameplay and of course our signature
storytelling and Rich World building
along with our spin on one of the most
classic monsters of all time vampires
it's been amazing to see how all of us
have pulled together to deliver our
vision for something new redfall is the
biggest most ambitious game we have ever
made our teams Dove head first into this
new opportunity and we can't wait for
you to experience redfall for yourself
thankfully you won't have to wait too
much longer red Falls coming on May 2nd
thank you again for joining us
soon in redfall here we go
thank you
foreign
[Music]